Let's go next to our caller from the three
zero three area code color from three zero
three who maybe is making tea or whistling
in the background.
Hello? Dude, are you there?
Yeah.
So are we on speaker or Bluetooth?
Um, give me one second.
I'm very good.
How's it going?
Hello?
Hello.
Yes, that's much better.
Yeah, the question man.
So yeah, I have a question.
So I'm leaning a little more.
I'm in the middle of either democratic or
Republican.
I had a question because I'm not too sure.
Like I see usually like CNN usually talks
bad about Trump and I just want to know what
do you, if any, do you have any policies that
you necessarily agree that he was put in place?
Are you a character that yeah, that Trump
has put in?
Yeah, I mean, listen, so one of the things
that I think overall Trump's tax plan was
a disaster, but one of the things he did is
he lowered the threshold, at which point medical
expenses become deductible.
I think that that's good.
You know, I think that that, I mean it's like,
it's, it's very, it's, it's pennies on the
dollar.
It's a drop in the bucket, but I think that
was the right decision.
Um, he made a couple of tiny little tweaks
around disclosure of pharmaceutical pricing
that I think are fine, but they, you know,
they don't really change the broader problems
we have.
Like, yeah, I can find little tiny things
if you, you know, kind of pushed my hand.
Sure.
Oh, I was just, I was curious because I don't
know, I've like, I've, I've been always in
the middle, like I don't necessarily agree
with all these gun rights that I think liberals
are more pushing or censorship kind of deal.
I do agree with somethings like health care,
but I just, I kind of find myself in the middle
and I, I'm having a hard time.
Well, but let me ask you this.
I mean, let's see.
Remind me what your name was.
I don't know if I caught it.
Oh wait, sorry.
It's Mackenzie.
Mackenzie.
Okay.
Mackenzie, listen are, when you look around,
do you think right now that we have an imbalance
of power in this country where the rich have
too much power or do you think that they don't?
Uh, I think they do.
Uh, and most places.
Yeah.
Okay.
And when you look around, do you think that
huge businesses are over-regulated and can't
make any money?
Or do you think that businesses are getting
away with things like paying no taxes while
raping and pillaging the environment?
Well, that's why I may disagree.
I do agree that they may be getting away with
some taxes, but if you look into like business
models and, uh, development or I guess ideas
that they, uh, put money and invest in, I
think that that's something that not a lot
of people look at.
Like, I don't know if you point out Amazon
and say, Oh, they haven't been taxed a lot
or it should be taxed more.
But you look at how we are getting two day
shipping, one day shipping something that
10 years ago you would've thought was, Oh
that's impossible.
I wouldn't be able to uh, get that object.
Right.
But when it comes to that one and two day
shipping, Mackenzie, if I were to tell you
the way Amazon is able to do that and do it
cheaply is by subcontracting those one day
delivery deliveries to underlie synced and
untrained third party delivery companies that
are getting into accidents that are, you know,
getting into all sorts of trouble.
And then Amazon says, Hey, it's not our problem.
They're not our employees.
That said, does that sound okay to you or
does that sound like a problem?
No, that does.
That definitely does sound like a problem.
I, I'm not too educated on that.
Got it.
And when you look around the world, Mackenzie,
and you see people like Rodrigo Duterte and
Kim Jong, Owen and Vladimir Putin and Bashar
Al Assad and whoever else are those, the types
of leaders that you want our president to
be more like or less like big picture for
me,
definitely less like, because I wasn't like,
uh, you know, the bad things that they do
over there.
I don't want to talk about that on the phone.
So listen, every, everything I've asked you
so far means that if you vote your values,
you could not possibly vote for Donald Trump
in 2020.
Now, which of the democratic candidates we
could talk about.
But I don't see anything in there that would
in any sensible way mean Oh, Trump is the
person that you would, you would be voting
for.
I just don't see any points of agreement.
Yeah, I, I definitely do agree there, but
I, I'm, I'm personally, I was a Bernie supporter.
Uh, I definitely liked the free college idea.
I mean, I don't personally go to college.
Okay.
Uh, but I do agree that like investing in
a younger class will definitely help the future,
but part of me is, is more on the fiscal side
of, I don't see where that money's going necessarily
come from.
Okay, well that's a bigger, that's a bigger
conversation, which, which we can have, but
listen, I'm glad we did this because to me,
and I think the audience will agree and check
out the YouTube comments when we upload this,
you're clearly someone who should be voting
for one of the democratic candidates in which
one kind of remains to be determined.
Absolutely.
Well, thank you for your time, David.
Be calling a lot more.
This is my first time calling you.
Thank you, sir.
All right, very good.
Appreciate the phone call.
I apologize that I am out of time, but I am
sorry to everybody I didn't get to.
I see Ronald Reagan is holding and a call
in earlier next.
I'm Ronald and I will definitely get to you